[Musique]
ensuite le monde agricole traverse une
crise absolument majeur c'est un
drame que vive tout à la fois
l'agriculture française et la ruralité
moi ça fait 35 ans que je fais ce métier
je l'ai fait par passion je suis né
dedans j'ai grandi dedans j'ai grandi
avec et je vis avec et c'est une
vocation on va dire tout simplement et
la crainte que j'ai c'est que les jeunes
qui arrive dans notre métier avec la
même passion que moi j'avais quand
j'étais jeune et ben ils aient pas la
possibilité de faire ce métier à cause
de de tout toutes ces complications qui
qui qui font que le métier devient de
plus en plus difficile à à gérer nous
avons une obligation
morale à l'égard de nos
agriculteurs la pâqu doit être
sanctuarisée je crois que que compte
tenu de la situation aujourd'hui des
agriculteurs et du monde rural il y a
besoin de faire des propositions les
constats sont là la baisse des prix qui
ne permet plus aux agriculteurs de vivre
la crise est malheureusement générale
pour toutes les filières et on ne peut
pas supporter d'entendre le gouvernement
nous dire qu'il n'y a plus rien à faire
au Républicain nous considérons que les
agriculteurs sont d'abord des
entrepreneurs et nous voulons travailler
à la compétitivité des entreprises
agricoles et bien sûr de toute la chaîne
c'està-d dire les agriculteurs les
transformateurs les industriels et puis
la grande distribution il faut un
nouveau partage des marges et il faut
surtout que la France retrouve toute sa
place au niveau européen où elle est
parfaitement absente parce que c'est
aussi là-bas que ça se passe aujourd'hui
l'essentiel de nos clients sont
d'énormes entreprises qui brassent
beaucoup d'animaux qui brassent beaucoup
de capitaux et nous si on veut se
défendre face face à ces géants il faut
à tout prix qu'on soit capable de se
regrouper pour pouvoir se défendre pour
pouvoir défendre notre produit pour
pouvoir défendre no nos produit est n
revenu tout simplement pour qu'on puisse
enfin se battre à armes égales contre
les Géants de de l'agroalimentaire si
chaque agriculteur seul dans son coin et
laisser face à la grande distribution
comment voulez-vous qu'il s'en sorte
c'est pour cette raison que j'ai
souhaité que nous nous engagions pour la
contractualisation qui est la seule
façon de rééquilibrer le rapport de
force aujourd'hui trop déséquilibré je
veux proposer aux AG culur de
s'organiser en filière pour mettre en
place une relation contractuelle entre
producteur transformateur et enfin
distributeur on a aussi d'énormes
problèmes avec toutes les normes qui
nous qui nous entourent et qui souvent
se contredisent et c'est là aussi qu'il
faudrait faire un grand tri essayer de
faire avancer l'riculture dans le bon
sens je souhaite que nous nous engagions
dans une démarche de
déconstruction de normes
national sol et
inefficace le gros souci qu'on a c'est
que l'Europe nous demande des choses et
bien souvent quand c'est quand la France
reprend ses
textes réapplique pour nous elle nous en
demande encore plus nous refuserons
toute norm européenn en France qui
serait supérieure à la moyenne des
normes
[Musique]
européennes pour la ruralité nous
envisageons un vaste plan Marchal il
n'est pas question d'abandonner les
territoires ruraux et on a décidé qu'à
chaque fois qu'on investirait 1 € pour
les zones urbaines on investirait 1 €
pour les zones rurales parce que nos
campagnes ne veulent pas mourir et nous
ne voulons pas qu'elle meure je crois
que c'est extrêmement important c'est
attendu et on ne peut pas abandonner nos
territoires qui font la richesse de
notre
[Musique]
pays